then from this you get people pandering
to them
the politicians people like rashid
delayed step up and they say something
like i'm going to say something mindless
and insane and hope that someone votes
for me because of it
and then the whole system just what is
this i'm looking at this tulabe quote
that police should be abolished because
this is from daily mail
because force is intentionally racist
this is the quote intentionally racist
and cannot be reformed
force is intentionally racist and cannot
be reformed
force is like a scientific phrase it's
not
it's it's it's a mechanical function
well so so rashida tulabe
in response to all of this tweeted it
wasn't an
accident policing in our country is
inherently and intentionally racist
dante wright was met with aggression and
violence i am done with those who
condone government-funded murder
no more policing incarceration and
militarization it can't
be reform okay let's take two seconds
here
first it was initially reported that
this guy dante wright was wanted on a
misdemeanor
gun charge and apparently he got stopped
they found out he had a gun
he fled now when i heard that i was like
sounds to me like his only crime was the
non-crime of
enjoying a second amendment rights if
that's the case
then this is absolutely wrong however
even if it was
in my opinion an unjustified and
unconstitutional act you don't
resist the police when they come to
arrest you
you you you have the privilege of a
trial to defend yourself and actually
fight for others in the process because
the precedent set by your cases
could help others in the future instead
he fought with the cops he dove into the
car
they knew he's on a weapons charge he
had a ruger 45 he ended up getting shot
and killed and it's a tragic story i
wish it didn't happen but come on
the cops need to be able to make arrests
the cops don't know who this guy is or
what his story is they don't know if
he's a good guy a bad guy
all they know is we got a warrant but
now it turns out it was it was an
aggravated robbery charge
so this warrant was actually like this
guy strangled a woman and demanded 800
from her at gunpoint okay hold on a
minute a little different
yeah he probably should be arrested for
that and he resisted and tried running
away
we have the story actually from the new
york post they say
dante wright had an open warrant related
to an armed
robbery against him when he was shot
dead sunday right 20 and another man had
been charged with first
degree attempted aggravated robbery in
december 2019
for allegedly trying to steal 820 from a
woman at gunpoint
according to henneman county district
court documents the pair had crashed at
the victim's home
crashed the victim's home in the city of
ossio after attending a party there
then demanded money the next morning
while flashing a gun authority said in
court papers
give me the effing money i'm not playing
around right told the woman
according to prosecutors the victim
refused and began screaming for both men
to leave records show
give me the money and we will leave
right allegedly told her give me the
money and we will go
the two men eventually left the home
without any dough according documents
wright was later arrested in the case
and released a hundred thousand dollars
bail
but he violated his bail conditions in
july when he failed to stay in touch
with his court monitor
the paper said according to the daily
mail he was also in possession of a gun
at some point after his arrest for the
robbery which was also in violation of
the condition of his bail release
so apparently that case was actually
derivative
of the fact that he tried shaking
someone he tried an armed robbery
now rasheeda toled here's what she you
got to think about what she's saying now
in this context
this the sheer absurdity of this it
wasn't an accident it clearly was an
accident
i i tweeted the cop should go to jail
because
two things you're responsible for what
comes out of your gun this was
a negligent shooting right it wasn't an
accident she was reaching for a weapon
she was intending to cause harm she
wasn't intending to kill him not murder
but negligence
also these police in the area need to at
this
how do they not realize the
ramifications the political consequences
of what they're doing
defending what's going on right now if
they genuinely believe
chauvin should was just doing his job
and these cops are being unjustly
prosecuted morale is low
shouldn't they stand up for themselves
so i i have very little empathy if any
for people who are like i know they're
gonna throw someone under the bus but
i'm gonna say
nothing and then i'll be fine even after
saying that i still recognize the
shooting was not intentional
i still recognize this guy broke the
lawn was resisting i still recognize
the altercation could have been avoided
it was the actions of the individual
being pulled over
cops got to do their job and rasheed
taleb is saying
no more policing okay
no more policing right and and and you
know i think as well that the the
circumstances that you identify there
certainly will be used
at the trial right if if charges if they
try and upcharge beyond
uh negligent manslaughter right because
that speaks to
the circumstances that police officers
face them in right when the dispatcher
says go to this school
it's going to be you know proceed with
caution armed dangerous
this you know um reasonable suspicion to
believe
that actually probable cause in this
case that there this person is capable
of
violence and the officer would say okay
i have fear that's why i didn't think
properly
but i do think the broader point in
terms of the political discourse
you know as you suggest has been heavily
weighted i just i guess i'm more
i do think there is again this this sort
of silent majority
yes needs to be more uh visible both at
a political level and at a populist
level
um but again it's to say it's the silent
trump voter again right that most people
think this is totally choose profanity
you know profanity of choice
um it it is interesting though
that we don't hold rasheed slay in
the same kind of disdain that we would
if you know donald trump you know some
of the things that president trump has
tweeted for example
uh you know that this is really this is
kind of ufo you know outer space stuff
except ufos are actually serious you
know you know what i will say
in terms of you know saying that the cop
should be arrested my my bigger
issue that that infuriates me with
everything
is that there are people who will
privately say to you
i'm so upset with what's going on and
then you're like all right will you
stand up with me oh no no
heavens no i won't take any risk it's
like
you know i've always uh i've always
respected the idea
that you know back in the day in these
wars the leader would be on a horse and
he would charge in
with his men and lead them into battle
now you've got people who are like yes
look at all these problems
oh i'm not going to say anything i don't
want to get canceled
you do it for me so when i see these
cops sitting back
while other cops are being demonized and
villainized thinking like
meh what do i care i won't speak up i
won't stand up i won't resign
i won't protest this i'm like okay if
you won't defend others
who have been put in these positions i'm
not going to defend you
i think this lady should go to prison i
think she should she i hope the system
comes for her
for all it's worth chauvin
as we're now learning it's not so so so
clear-cut exactly what happened
and why floyd lost his life and they're
trying to charge him with second-degree
murder
now manslaughter might make sense
there's an argument for there and in
fact the state
may have actually convinced the jury of
that we'll see what happens the defense
is arguing
tomorrow and thursday and then i think
they're off friday and then
deliberations begin but murder two and
three are insane
the fact that the system charged him
with this in the first place was nuts
he's probably gonna get quit on that
charge there's probably gonna be riots
keith ellison right right hyper
political
exactly looking for his own future
aspirations at the expense of the law
but i i what bothers me is that there
were a lot of good cops
who walked when this went down and they
said if you're going to play this game
i won't be a part of it and i applaud
those cops because those are the good
cops
some of them are probably actually bad
people but they're willing to stand up
at least for themselves
now this cop just seems like another one
of these people who thinks that as the
world is burning down around them
they can say nothing and do nothing and
they'll be fine it won't come for them
i talk about this all the time with like
the wokeness the critical race theory
stuff
where people are like i know it's bad
but as long as i keep my head down i'll
be fine no you won't
if this really is as bad as people think
it is eventually it will come for you
and there's no escaping it your best
chance now is to speak up
otherwise there will be no one left to
speak up for you now she's been involved
in this
the political system is dominated by
these activists the city manager got
fired for calling for due process and
i'm just like
well i mean you knew this was going to
happen you knew it's what they called
for last year you knew they
literally voted to abolish the police
one town over 10 miles from you why
should i
why should i have sympathy for this a
lot a lot of people i know
a lot of good people i've talked to in
the minnesota minneapolis area
have straight up said yeah we're moving
we're leaving right we won't be a part
of this we won't let our tax dollars
fund this and then a bunch of people
just shrugged it off and said oh
whatever
okay well now you get to be chauvin but
i do think you know again
this stuff does hit a i i agree with you
in the broad
need to identify to call out that you
know
the council culture you know the the
fake workery whatever
um but at the point of paying taxes as
you suggest i think a lot of people like
enough because the especially on these
policing matters
it's not simply the matter of taxes it's
taxes for
you know an exigent interest right
protection of self and family
and when you combine those two factors
you know i do think we will
i mean this is just going to be a
developing trend it's also i think at
the political
level ultimately why the rashida delay
crowd
uh is gonna lose ultimately ultimate
ultimate yeah sure i mean look president
trump really
nearly won right and i i do agree with
you i do
that they'll end up losing yeah it just
the problem is
it's not going to happen until there's
widespread violence and destruction on a
scale that we will regret
i'm sure many people are upset about
what happened last year with the george
floyd riots
regret is a hard word to use because it
caught everyone off guard
and now we're looking back at like how
do we stop this
anger you know for the people who rioted
and looted
now we have an option we have a chance
are we going to stand up and do
something before it's too late
apparently the answer is no
obviously you know we'll talk about this
people who are watching the show
understand what's going on
but too many regular people have been
ignoring this the cops in brooklyn
center
thought they would be allowed to get
past the lunatic woke outrage mob
they thought they would be safe are you
kidding me your
your fellow officers are going down in
flames and being sacrificed at the woke
altar
and you did nothing you said nothing you
said i'll be fine well now you're not
fine
so that that these cops have a chance if
they all resigned today
by tomorrow the police would be totally
funded
they'd have better training much of
these problems would be solved they'd be
better equipped they'd be safer
the problem isn't that police have too
much funding is that they have too
little funding we are asking people and
and these activists don't remember this
these cops are human beings
to go into situations where people want
to kill them we've seen the videos
they're scary videos
where someone reaches into their car we
saw the guy in in in wisconsin in
kenosha
when he was going to his car he grabbed
the knife and the cop shot him
and then they riot in that city
apparently that cop is back on duty
actually
i don't think he did anything wrong like
someone grabbed a knife this guy had
assaulted a woman
these people don't realize this about
these cops that these they're not
vicious and depraved murderers
and many of these people are
psychologically damaged after being
involved in these shootings i mean this
woman
i really do believe she accidentally
shot this guy dante she went holy s
i just shot him i don't think she meant
to do that i'm sure she's been crying
non-stop right
mentally just fractured because of this
so with respect i'm not trying to be
mean
if the police right now said to the
people we have been dealing with riots
nonstop for a year
we have begged for your support and
instead all we have gotten was
defunded insulted demoralized abolished
and scapegoated our city is all yours
i think the moral way to do it though
would be to give you know a period of
notice
30 days because because then you can
balance because that's actually much
better
because then at least you know when you
do it say hey it's not this is now
the political responsibility right the
crimes that happen in that window
of absent policing uh but but you know i
also think as well the delusion right
that that
that anyone who says like rashida to
leave you know policing get rid of it
incarceration doesn't work great you
know
these are not people who have been
exposed to criminality
right police officers you know that
anyone who knows anyone who's been to
prison uh
i think would come out and say there are
a lot of people in there who
had really a bad start to life uh could
they have been diverted
um there are also a lot of people who
are really not nice people
yeah and when we're talking not nice
we're like you know
really not nice and and and so police
officers dealing with that every day
um one of the things i found interesting
is like
in some ways british humor is very
similar to like american police humor
it's very dark
and i think part of the translation and
it does british humor doesn't sometimes
translate in the united states and i
think part of the reason police officers
or a big reason is that you know you're
just dealing
every day with tragic circumstances
you're doing a lot of good but you're
also dealing with
really unpleasant people yeah and that
takes a toll
did you hear about the the cash bail
thing in new york where they're they
they want to get rid of it
or they they get they got rid of it i'm
sorry i i i actually didn't no
so uh earlier in the year like last year
they there was this bill where they said
basically if you're arrested for a
certain
you know certain non-violence oh mr mean
at the level yeah right
you will be auto released order right so
no bail because
here's the challenge man i don't like
the idea of charging people money to get
out of jail
right wait because innocent until proven
guilty it's better that the guilty
escape
then you know innocent suffer all that
stuff blackstone's formulation but there
was apparently one guy
who got arrested several times he kept
getting released and
apparently in a quote he was laughing he
was like y'all caught me doing it and
let me go
right it's like we have to it's the
constitution but
some people are bad people and we know
it right and it's and
it's and it's tough to deal with these
people while maintaining constitutional
rights
but there is an interesting issue here
as well that you know
one of the controversies for some is
that the police the judges are elected
here right at
a local level yeah and and you know i do
think there can be a cost to that that
that
the reflex can be more punitive
sometimes for certain crimes but
the benefit is that you can avoid a
situation for example
uh that exists uh in much of europe
certainly in the uk in britain where um
the cops are arresting people and
they've got a rap sheet that is just
pages and pages
long and the the judges are still sort
of you know
90 day community service centers and how
that and not simply the the
and the immorality of that in a
democratic society
um but also how that corrodes the public
trust which the
public ultimately in a democracy must be
the guardians right or must be the
masters
how they have no essentially you know
the judiciary accepted
separate to the political um branch but
there's no input right that they just
simply see
exactly and people eventually just like
they lose faith
this is the system the system is
supposed to work because of judges
because a judge can look at a person and
say
you committed you're accused of this
crime what say you if the person says
your honor i beg of you i have to work
my job and be with my kids
i will be in court and the judge can be
like okay let's let's set some
conditions
that aren't cash because you can't
afford it where we can ensure you will
come to work how about
house arrest but with a provision for
you go to work
right instead i've seen these videos
where the judge is like
your bailout set is a thousand dollars
your honor i i watch this video
it was maddening the guy's like your
honor please please i have to go to i
have to be with my family i have to work
my job i'll lose my job if i'm in jail
and he goes i said one thousand dollars
bang and i'm like that to me doesn't
work
because now maybe in this instance the
guy actually was a bad dude who was just
trying to pull a fast one but then you
have the inverse where you just
mentioned
in new york it's like your honor we
arrested this guy
all right i understand the cashless bail
thing but like here's his rap sheet
he's been convicted of seven crimes in
the past can we at least hold this guy
no free to go right the judge is
supposed to be interpreting this better
and i feel like too often we don't get
it we get
but maybe maybe maybe it's because
there's no real simple answer maybe
we're going to learn about the harsh
cases and the lacks cases maybe the
reality is
you know there's good judges in the
middle who find that middle ground and
that and and
all this right the same thing in san
francisco right that they were not
arresting
you know certain things would be treated
misdemeanor stealing from a car you know
anonymous right right right and and
actually that's a much better example
you look at um
you know the the kind of woke element
the left right and it's easy it's much
easier to become part of the work crowd
and wave
than it is to be like you know kind of
larry david out of kirby enthusiasm and
be like
you know like it's okay for them right
because they can go to the apartment
building that has a concierge
and an underground garage but that small
business owner
or that you know person who doesn't have
you know has to park their car on the
street
that working class lower income person
they're the ones who are suffering the
most
it's not the people who are pushing this
the most but again i just think there is
a political opportunity here
that that uh we have to believe will be
taken advantage of
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time